Recibí una visita, hace casi exactamente un año,
hace un poquito más de un año, de una persona de muy alto grado del Departamento de Defensa.
Vino a verme y dijo: "mil seiscientos de los chicos que hemos mandado allá
han vuelto sin al menos un brazo completo.
El brazo completo. Desde la articulación del hombro.
Y estamos haciendo lo mismo, más o menos,
que hemos hecho desde la guerra civil, que es un palo y un gancho.
Y merecen más que eso".
Y este tipo, sentado en mi oficina en New Hampshire, dijo literalmente:
"Quiero que me de algo que le podamos poner a estos chicos
que sea capaz de recoger una uva o pasa de la mesa
para que la puedan poner en sus bocas sin destruir cualquiera de estas dos,
y que sean capaces de notar la diferencia sin tener que mirarla".
Que, como entienden, tenga una respuesta eferente, aferente y háptica.
Terminó su explicación, y me quedé esperando la enorme propuesta de 300 libras de papel
y él dijo: "Eso es lo que quiero que haga".
Le respondí: "Mire, está loco. Esa tecnología simplemente no existe aún
y no puede hacerse.
No con la forma de un brazo humano
con 21 grados de libertad, desde el hombro a la punta de los dedos".
Me dijo: "Como dos docenas de estos 1.600 chicos han vuelto sin los dos brazos.
¿Cree que perder un brazo es malo?
Es sólo un inconveniente comparado a que hayas perdido ambos".
Tengo un trabajo de día
y mis noches y fines de semana ya están ocupados con cosas del tipo de
cómo proveer de agua y energía al mundo y educar a todos los niños;
de lo cual, Chris, no voy a hablar ahora. No necesito otra misión.
Me quedo pensando sobre estos chicos sin brazos.
Él me cuenta: "Hemos trabajado un poco en esto por todo el país.
Tenemos unos neurólogos y otras personas bastante impresionantes".
Le dije: "Haré un viaje de estudio, iré a ver lo que tienen hecho".
Durante el siguiente mes visité un montón de lugares, algunos por acá, otros por el resto del país,
y encontré lo mejor de lo mejor.
Fui a Washington, vi a estos tipos y les dije:
"Hice lo que me pidieron. Vi lo que existe por ahí.
Todavía creo que están locos. Pero no tan locos como pensaba".
Junté un equipo hace un poco más de trece meses
y llegamos a ser como 20 personas.
Dijimos, vamos a construir un dispositivo que haga lo que él quiere.
Incluimos 14 de los 21 grados de libertad;
no necesitas los de los dos dedos más pequeños.
Y construimos esta cosa.
Hace un par de semanas lo llevamos al hospital Walter Reed,
que desafortunadamente ha salido bastante en las noticias estos días.
Se lo mostramos a un grupo de chicos.
Uno de ellos se definió como suertudo
porque siendo diestro perdió su brazo izquierdo.
Estaba sentado en una mesa con siete u ocho de estos chicos.
Dijo que tenía suerte porque todavía tenía su brazo útil
y después se alejó empujándose de la mesa. No tenía piernas.
Estos chicos tienen una actitud simplemente increíble.
Entonces ahora voy a mostrarles un corto de 30 segundos,
sin la cubierta de piel, y ahí termino.
Pero entiendan: estarán mirando algo
que hicimos lo suficientemente pequeño para que le quede a una mujer mediana,
para que se le pueda poner a cualquiera de estos chicos.
Va a ir dentro de algo que hacemos usando escaneos computarizados
y resonancias magnéticas del que sea su brazo bueno
con lo cual haremos una versión en goma de silicona, que se cubrirá y pintará en 3D
para hacer una copia que sea un reflejo exacto del otro brazo.
Así que no podrán ver todas las cosas geniales que están en esta serie elástica de 14 actuadores
donde cada uno de estos es capaz de detectar temperatura y presión.
Tiene también un rotador de hombro neumático que lo sujeta al brazo
de modo de que mientras más se aumenta la carga, más fuerte se sujeta.
Le sacan la carga y vuelve, nuevamente, a ser fácil de usar.
Voy a mostrarles a un tipo haciendo un par de cosas sencillas
que exhibimos en Washington. ¿Podemos verlo?
Miren como los dedos agarran. El pulgar sube. Su muñeca.
Esto pesa 3,1 kilogramos.
Va a rascarse la nariz.
Tiene 14 grados de libertad activos.
Ahora va a recoger un lápiz con su pulgar y su dedo índice.
Ahora lo va a dejar en la mesa, toma una hoja de papel,
rota todos los grados de libertad de su mano y su muñeca, y la lee.
(Aplausos).